mesdames messieurs bon dimanche le
gouvernement fédéral avait-il épuisé
tous ces recours quand il a invoqué la
Loi sur les mesures d'urgence pour
mettre un terme aux manifestations à
ottawaï à la frontière c'est la question
à laquelle Justin Trudeau essaie de ces
ministres devait répondre devant la
commission rouleau des témoignages
détaillés un regard unique sur la façon
dont le fédéral a géré la crise sur les
raisons qui ont mené à l'utilisation de
cette mesure exceptionnelle entre la
présence d'éléments radicaux et la
menace à l'économie plusieurs
justifications ont été mises de la vente
pour le ministre de la Sécurité publique
c'est un coup de fil de la commissaire
de la GRC qui est devenu le point de
bascule je me suis entretenu avec Marco
menichino mais d'abord le fil des
événements dans les heures qui ont
précédé l'invocation de la Loi sur les
mesures d'urgence telles que racontée
par Justin Trudeau devant la commission
il y a eu une bonne discussion autour de
la table tous les ministres qui
voulaient parler ont pu parler et sans
partager les délibérations je peux dire
qu'on est sorti avec un consensus clair
que je devais procéder au prochaines
étapes de consultation avec les premiers
ministres avec la possibilité d'invoquer
la Loi sur les mesures d'urgence Marco
medicino bonjour merci d'être avec nous
merci Monsieur medicino ministre de la
Sécurité publique vous étiez la semaine
dernière devant la commission rouleau
est-ce que vous avez l'impression que
vous que vos collègues ministres avaient
convaincu la Commission et les Canadiens
que la Loi sur les mesures d'urgence
elle était nécessaire
oui j'espère mais tout d'abord je vous
souligner que le dernier rivière nous
avons en situation qui était sans
précédent il y a plein des blocages
illégal à les frontières et incluant ici
à l'appartement à Haute-Loire ça c'est
les raisons qu'on avait invoqué la loi
de mercure de l'agence c'est un c'est un
réseau qui a la dernière écoute c'est
une grosse mesure c'est une grande
décision c'est une décision qu'on
apprend à avec beaucoup d'attention mais
les conséquences et l'impact allait
travailler à la famille à tout le monde
était
décembre précédent donc avec beaucoup de
consultations avec les services
policières avec toutes les niveaux des
gouvernements à la provinces les
municipalités on apprend la décision la
dernière semaine j'ai un opportunité
pour bien expliquer tous les
circonstances toutes les facteurs qui a
contribué à cette décision historique la
semaine dernière vous vos collègues
ministres sont allés devant la
commission vous avez tous évoqué des
raisons différentes ou un moment clé
différent vous vous avez dit à coup s'il
y avait des armes ça a été le moment
charnière pour moi Madame féline de dire
c'est une question d'intérêt économique
la frontière était fermée à Windsor
d'autres disaient le centre-ville
d'Ottawa était paralysé il fallait
bouger c'est quoi la justification c'est
quoi la vraie raison c'est toutes les
facteurs qui a contribué à la décision
donc en tant que ministre de la Sécurité
publique oui
j'ai regardé toutes les portes d'entrée
tous les frontières tous les toutes les
situations en haute voix et c'était
vraiment difficile pour les services
policières pas seulement pour restaurer
le sécurité publique mais aussi pour
maintenir la sécurité donc dans mon avis
il faut arrêter le wakamol approche
qu'on a regardé pendant le 2 semaines et
vraiment c'était l'appel avec le
commissaire de la GRC le jour avant
seulement 11 avant l'invocation de la
loi de merzou degence était lancée ou
elle m'a dit le situation à cuts à une
situation avec une selle avec beaucoup
des armes d'affaires avec un idéologies
ou les gens là veulent bataille juste la
fin n'importe quoi c'est c'est un moment
ou dans mon avis on a traversé le test
ça c'était la ligne que vous avez
franchi
vous a aussi envoyé un courriel qui
disait dans les heures qui ont précédé
l'invocation de la Loi sur les mesures
d'urgence un courriel qui disait on n'a
pas tout épuisé les ressources en notre
disposition on a encore des moyens
pourtant vous avez quand même évoqué la
loi pourquoi tout d'abord la commissaire
de n'a pas discuté cette avis avec moi
en personne directement elle a envoyé
cette courriel à mon chef de cabinet
mais au même temps on a parlé un peu
plus tôt le même journée et c'était le
conversation directement qui a démontré
à moi que sa préoccupation était c'est
une situation très grave très au sérieux
et c'était toutes les langues qu'elle a
utilisé dans cette conversation qui a
influencé mon avis qu'on avait traversé
un moment unique vous avez
vous avez évoqué on a évoqué David
Vignaud le directeur du SARS a évoqué en
lors de son témoignage le fait que selon
lui la définition de menace à la
sécurité nationale telle qu'elle est
écrite dans la loi n'était pas rempli
par les conditions mais que vous aviez
une opinion juridique qui faisait en
sorte que bon ça se défendait est-ce que
vous avez
taillé un peu l'opinion juridique pour
faire en sorte que la loi soit
applicable mais il faut comprendre que
si c'est ça une mandat qui est où
ils sont familiés avec
les menaces avec espionnage avec
d'ingérence étrangers avec des attaques
cyber donc ça c'est
les conventions et les menaces que si
c'était bien familier avec c'est pas la
même situation c'est pas la même
situation exactement et ça c'est
exactement que le directeur de la C6 à
offrir à la jugeu que même si les
définitions dans le loi de 6 n'était pas
satisfiée dans le contexte plus grand de
le droit de mesure de gens les décisions
d'évocation était justifiées donc ça je
pense être un de les laissant plus
important qu'on peut prendre à la fin de
cet exercice de l'examen comment il faut
peut-être moderniser tous nos outils
dans le communauté d'intelligence tous
nos outils dans la communauté des
services policiers est-ce que est-ce que
la loi qui régit les services canadiens
de renseignement de sécurité devraient
être mis à jour mais je pense et c'est
une convention qui continuait avec moi
et le directeur et même à partout dans
dans le gouvernement fédéral et ça
reconnaitre que les menaces est
différent aujourd'hui de il y a dit
ou les dernières fois qu'on a introduire
des lois pour offrir des outils à la
communauté d'intelligence la loi
essentiellement
c'est maintenant un peu plus vieux donc
il faut mademniser il faut faire une
mise à jour à la lumière de ce qui s'est
passé en février dernier quelles leçons
votre gouvernement attirer de tout ça
tout d'abord que les menaces à ont
évolué il faut aussi comprendre comment
on peut répondre avec plus de
coordination entre tous les niveaux des
services policières tous les niveaux de
gouvernement maintenant il y a un lacuna
entre les lois des services policières
pour tous les provinces et les
territoires et les lois de mesure
d'urgence donc comment on peut peut-être
mettre en place
proposition où il y a plus de connexion
entre tous les services policières de
collaboration donc pour éviter pour
permettre à ces gens au service
policiers de travailler ensemble sans
avoir à invoquer la loi exactement et je
pense que ça c'est une de la leçon
j'espère c'est une de les leçons qu'on
peut étudier quand on reçut le rapport
final de le juge ou l'autre
si le rapport vital du juge rouleau
justement il dit que vous étiez pas
justifié de l’invoquer la loi vous allez
dire quoi mais tout le monde a fait le
meilleur dans des circonstances très
très dur et en tant que ministre de
sécurité publique le top job est de
protéger toutes les Canadiens et ça
c'est exactement les résultats de le de
les décisions d'invocation de loi de
mesures d'urgence quel que soit quel que
soit ce que va vous dire le juge rouleau
vous êtes convaincu que vous avez pris
la bonne décision oui tout à fait parce
que c'est une situation sans précédent
parce que les conséquences à tous les
Canadiens canadiennes étaient sans
précédent et parce que après beaucoup de
réflexion on apprend de décision pour
protéger tous les Canadiens et c'était
c'est une décision qu'on apprend à
l'intérêt public à tout le monde ma
communicino merci infinie merci à vous